حرب الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا تهيمن على نقاشات
قمه مجموعه ال 20 منذ انطلاقها هذا الصباح
استمعنا الى رئيس الاندونيسي جوك ودود
الذي دعى الى اهميه صنع السلام وانهاء هذه
الحرب الحرب كانت ايضا الموضوع الابرز في
لقاء بين الرئيسين الصيني الشجنبي
والفرنسيه
حسب مصدر في قصر الاليزيه فانما تكون طلب
من سجن المساعده في الضغط
الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا وبدئي مفاوضاتي
السلام
متقاربه الى حد ما مع روسيا وكانت قد تجنب
استخدام وصف حرب في حديثها عن هذا الغزو
عندما تتحدث عن مجرد ازمه هناك بكل
الاحوال دنيا ملكيه ايجابيه همم
بنك حسب
عن اهميه مساعده الدول الناميه التي تعاني
من عواقب هذه حرب في مجال الامن الغذائي
وفي مجال همم الطاقه نعلم ان من المكون
يسعى الى الضغط من اجل تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود هذا
الاتفاق الذي ينتهي في التاسع عشر من
الشهر الحالي الطرفان تجنبا الحديث في
المواضيع الخلافيه همم المساله التايوانيه
تم ذكرها بشكل مختصر وقال لنا مصدر في
الاليزي همم انه بما ان الطرفين الذي
يغيره من موقفيهما في مجال همم المساله
التايوانيه فان همم الرئيسين لم يدخل في
تفاصيل هذه المساله تجنب ايضا الحديثه مع
السجن حول حقوق الانسان في منطقه الشنجان
الصينيه
للامم المتحده اتهم السلطات الصينيه هناك
بارتكاب بانتهاكات لحقوق الانسان بحق
الاقليات المسلمه